[Music]
good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock could it be a gray day for the
pm he's still waiting for that report
from sue gray about dining street party
allegations to drop into his inbox it
could come in the next few hours and it
could be grim reading and we're just
hearing within the last couple of
seconds that number 10 telling us they
still have not received sue grey's
report the police are investigating
could he be the first prime minister to
be interviewed under caution the foreign
secretary lives trusts on the programme
very shortly we'll also speak to
labour's bridget phillipson and the
smp's ian blackford
it's wednesday the 26th of january
grayday the prime minister expected to
receive the party gate report as soon as
today as sky news learns part of the
evidence is photos of him close to other
people and bottles of wine
after the police launched a criminal
investigation into parties at downing
street the prime minister is preparing
for a grilling at pmqs we'll bring you
that live at midday
punishing putin fighting talk from the
u.s president gets personal the sky news
joins ukrainian forces on the frozen
front line
these are the most sophisticated
attacks available to the ukrainian
military trying to keep them hidden it's
going to be vitally important
that they're operational and are kept
safe in case the russians invade
fire spike in omicron cases in children
could lead to another surge in adults
we'll take you through the data
let it blow a warning that climate
change could be threatening the winter
olympics as fake snow is used to boost
the slopes
clothes horse the rider with the royal
link that took paris fashion week by
storm
[Music]
also on the programme for you this
morning covey travel rules will change
again from the 11th of february so can
the holiday industry finally bounced
back i'll be speaking to a range of
travel experts later on in the programme
and deep dive the expedition to survey
the marine ecosystem that's developed
around the sunken wreck of the titanic
[Music]
good morning the prime minister is
waking up this morning to one of the
most crucial days in his premiership and
the breaking news in the last minute
number 10 telling us they have still not
received the sue gray report sue gray's
party gate report into whether lockdown
rules were broken could though drop into
his inbox in the next couple of hours
after police announced they're launching
a criminal investigation into downing
street gatherings expected to be grim
reading in parts
big question this morning can he survive
let's take you through the key
developments for today here they are if
police decide to interview boris johnson
under caution it would be the first time
ever that that's happened to a prime
minister
we believe mr johnson hasn't yet
received sue grey's report but it is
expected to make a statement after it's
been published
and the senior civil servant you may
have heard of us sue gray is
investigating 16 we're told 16 1-6
alleged parties we believe police are
investigating more than half of those
sky news understands ms gray has
received photographs which show mr
johnson and others close together with
wine bottles when covered rules were in
place
his future may be uncertain but what is
certain is he'll face a grueling prime
minister's questions later on today
we'll bring that to you live of course
on sky news at midday
samdi who will be there offering him
support is the foreign secretary liz
tross she is with us this morning good
morning thank you very much indeed are
we writing saying that danny street
hasn't yet received the sugree report
that's correct and of course it's an
independent report it's uh a matter for
sugree
when she sends that report when she's
when she's completed her work okay when
she does we will see all of it
we have been absolutely clear that we
will publish the findings of the report
we don't we don't know the content of
the report so there could be
for example security issues that mean uh
parts of it are problematic to publish
but we will absolutely publish the
findings of the report and we'll be able
to say more when we see the report sure
i mean previously last week i think
downing street said that they would repo
publish the report in full
that's basically the same as what you're
saying exactly that's a national
security issue
well unless there is some specific issue
but we want to make the findings of the
report public
we want to be open and transparent
that's why sue gray has been asked to do
that report okay um
if he has broken the law or misled
parliament should he resign
the prime minister has appeared before
parliament
he has apologized
for what has happened
he's admitted that mistakes were made
and i 100 support him
and want him to continue as prime
minister this is what he actually said
on the 8th of december if you'll just
indulge us we'll share this with our
viewers here we go
i can understand
how infuriating it must be to think that
the people who have been setting the
rules have not been following the rules
mr speaker because i
was also furious to see that clip
i have been
repeatedly assured
since these allegations emerged
that there was no party
and that and that no
kovid rules were broken
if it's proven that he was at a party
should he resign i'm not going to
prejudice the findings
of the sugree report um
or indeed the police investigation
that is now taking place about what
happened
what i'm saying kay
is the prime minister has apologized for
what has happened
he said mistakes were made
i believe that he's done a fantastic job
as prime minister
whether it's delivering brexit
uh delivering the covered vaccines the
booster programs we've now got a much
faster growing economy than many of our
competitors thanks to his work and i
believe that's what we should focus on
uh well um you can't prejudice the
report of course because she's already
done it um the question is uh when i
suppose let me ask you this then when
were you aware of the police
investigation
uh i was aware yesterday it would be a
before investigation before or after um
cabinet
well personally i was aware after
cabinet yeah apparently all your
colleagues in cabinet were aware after
cabinet but the prime minister knew
before do you think he should have told
you before
well i
i found out after kaepernick same time
as the rest of us
well i'm you know i think it was made
public and it's a matter
the police are not uh their operation
the independent from the government so i
think it's right that the uh government
finds out after the police have made
have made that decision and after the
public as well this is uh this is what
uh crested dick uh said yesterday just
in case you missed it
there was evidence that those involved
knew
or ought to have known
that what they were doing was an offence
do you think she needs the prime
minister
well
we have to wait to see what is the
outcome of the police investigation in
the same way as we need to see uh what
the outcome is of the sue grey report
you'll appreciate kay that i am spending
the majority of my time working on the
very serious situation uh with russia
and ukraine we'll come on to that where
we have and we'll come on
we will come on the point the point i'm
making is i'm not following every single
in and out of definition if your prime
minister is about to be questioned under
caution the first time ever i'm guessing
that's way up on your in your inbox so
it's a matter for the police okay but as
foreign secretary you must be concerned
if the prime minister is the first prime
minister ever to be questioned under
caution well as i've said the prime
minister has apologized in parliament uh
for what has happened he said that
mistakes were made
he commissioned the sugray report
he commissioned we're talking about
hypotheticals here okay we're not are we
because we've seen we absolutely well
there's a police investigation now and
that's been triggered by the fact that
photographs of the prime minister
where wine was near him um have been
given to the police we also know that he
was in the cabinet room um and there was
cake there as well i'm saying what you
were saying is speculation
what we need to do is wait for the
results of the suga gray report and the
police investigation tony blair said
that if he was questioned under caution
he would resign do you think that your
uh prime minister has the moral backbone
to do the same
well
you know tony blair's got his own
opinions
what i'm doing is waiting for the
outcome of both the secret report and
the police investigation where we will
get the full analysis
of exactly what happened uh yeah but
if i mean you're asking me to speculate
about i'm absolutely not all absolutely
not mistrust i'm absolutely not all i'm
saying to you as foreign secretary if
your prime minister the first lord of
the treasury is uh likely to be
questioned under caution tony blair when
he was in that position said i will
resign rather than that happen i'm just
asking whether your prime minister has
the moral backbone to do the same
what i'm saying to you is that until we
see
the results of the investigation both
the sue grey report and indeed the
police investigation it would be foolish
to speculate okay little known defense
that the rules um didn't apply
apparently to crime property um although
it applied to the rest of us didn't
apply to crime property is that
something that the prime minister should
consider as a defense
uh as i've said you know we are waiting
for the outcome
which will give us well
i don't think it is a reasonable
question because it is hypothetical
speculation about the future
rather than i'm just saying waiting for
the results of this there is there is a
loophole that says that you could have
events like this on crime property
number 10 i'm guessing is crime property
in fact i'm pretty sure it is should
that be something the prime minister
considers and then he isn't bringing the
whole party and government into
districts i can assure you this is
something in my role as foreign
secretary i'm not looking at okay
yesterday he certainly didn't seem to
have any ringing support from the deputy
prime minister this is what dominick
robb said yesterday
the government will continue in all
eventualities uh continuously in a
stable way but i think you're getting
ahead of yourself uh we'll wait for the
outcome of the inquiries that sue grey
is conducting hardly ringing endorsement
does the prime minister have your
support he has my 100
full support no unwavering absolutely
absolutely doesn't matter total support
he has my complete support very good uh
let's move on to rishi sooner uh should
we um he we know that the chancellor i'm
sure you saw uh the allegations at this
stage that um rishi sunak was he was at
this downing street event that was
actually uh paying respects to the nhs
workers that um had sadly lost their
lives and then just a couple of weeks
later there was the event in that room
uh which is uh
several people including
the interior designer have told us that
she was at that event which she sunk was
also there uh does he have questions to
answer
as i've said we are waiting for the
results of this investigation it sounds
like well the
sue gray report okay it sounds like so
after sue gray sounds like it sounds
like it will come out very soon so i
suggest we wait
for the facts rather than discuss
various pieces of speculation
about what might or might have a
statement yesterday mistrust to say that
she was there because she'd been asked
uh to have a meeting with the prime
minister as i said yesterday i can't
believe that in the middle of a pandemic
an interior designer came down three
flights of stairs went into another
building and then into the incredibly
secure cabinet room without being
invited what we need kate is the full
facts
and that means that sue gray who has
spoken to all of the people
uh involved in the situation putting
those facts together and giving us a
full picture okay i'm not going to
comment on
this speculation or this claim by a
given individual so we're waiting for
sue gray's report but not for the police
investigation to conclude you'll be able
to talk to us more about what what went
on i'm very happy to come on your show
and say nothing grey reports has been
published and talk about what's in it
okay great i'm very happy to come on
your show yeah once the police have
completed their investigations and so
that's twice you've promised i'll make
sure that
i'm extremely keen to come on your show
i'm always delighted to have you as you
can imagine miss trust did you go to any
parties that's not speculation i didn't
any
no were you ever invited
no
are you hesitated
oh no i wasn't okay okay
okay some mps have said that we need a
sense of proportion over the prime
minister being given a bit of cake do
you agree
look as i've said we need to wait to see
the outcome of the report and we need to
see exactly what happened and i don't
think it's helpful
to speculate on specific claims or
specific
accusations about what may or may not
have happened okay what about the full
facts okay we do uh what about this we
won't have to wait long apparently
scaring mps by suggesting the pm will be
able to uh scrutinize any letters of no
confidence that have been sent to the
1922 committee chairman that's not right
that can't happen well i have complete
trust in segre and brady
to run the process properly it is a
confidential process he's always done
that in the past and i'm sure he'll
continue to do completely confidential
any scam and he does have
you know he does have the complete
confidence of the parliamentary party
and the rocket does okay this picture of
kiyostama um given the police
investigation into the prime minister
should the police also be looking at
what happened in durham in april of last
year when kia stammer was having a beer
and a body
indoors when it was not allowed this is
a matter for the police and one of the
great things about the united kingdom is
we have a police force that is
operationally independent
politicians don't go around deciding who
should be investigated and who should
not be investigated would it be because
i think it would be very dangerous
for
to live in a country where politicians
get their opponents investigated so it's
a matter for the police would it be
further if the prime minister of the
land was investigated and the leader of
the opposition was not it depends on the
evidence and that's a matter for the
police there
it's picture there of him there you go
there he is in durham with a beer and a
buddy hey neither you or i
are police officers no that's right we
don't we don't have the
uh ability to or we don't have the train
to look at the evidence to decide
whether or not uh that that should be
taken forward it's a matter for the
police should the police you can ask me
about matters for me to do with foreign
policy they don't know if he broke the
law unless he invest they investigate so
should they at least investigate
well i'm sure the police are looking at
all of these circumstances okay and
looking at whether they should
investigate which is their job which
they do very well here we go safer
ground ukraine what should we do
well we are already supplying support to
ukraine we're supplying defensive
weapons
we're providing economic support
and we are urging
russia to desist from an incursion and
we're making it very clear that if they
were to do that there would be severe
economic cost to russia severe sanctions
we're working with our friends and
allies sanctions they would they would
target individuals uh they would target
financial institutions and they would be
coordinated with all of our allies
across
europe uh the united states and others
and what if russia decides to invade
economic sanctions would we be looking
at anything other than that
what we are doing is we are providing
defensive support to ukraine
we're bolstering nato so we've already
got enhanced forward presence we've
already got troops in estonia nato is
looking at what more it can do i was in
brussels on monday talking to the
secretary general about the uk
contribution to that
and we will also make sure
that there are severe consequences in
terms of sanctions
on russia yeah if they were to stage an
incursion i wonder if i could just ask
you about in individuals are being
sanctioned because we've heard obviously
what um joe biden has said and he's
suggesting that it should actually be
president the president president putin
also have individual sanctions is that
something that we would support we're
not ruling anything out and we will be
bringing forward new legislation to make
our sanctions regime tougher so we were
able to target more companies and
individuals in russia would be a great
president we'll be bringing that forward
in the next few days i'm not ruling that
out okay um i wonder if i could just
bring you back to um we're almost out of
time but i just wanted to bring you back
to a situation that will concern lots of
my viewers this morning and that's a
national insurance increase i believe
the cabinet is split over that which
side are you on cabinet has made the
decision to proceed with the national
insurance increase and we're all behind
that and there are no you're not allowed
to change that you're you're wondering
we have a we have a process we've made
collective decisions and we are moving
forward so it's not something that will
be reconsidered no to save the prime
minister's skin
no okay um
final thought before i let you go and
normally i i've got maybe seven or eight
questions and i don't get through them
all i've done 16 17. that's because
you're not really giving me very much
this morning well you're asking me
questions about a report that hasn't
been published in an investigation that
hasn't been yeah but we do have some
facts to the extent um that people that
were actually at these events have said
that they were there and we've also seen
photographs of the prime minister
relaxing in the garden and we've also
seen evidence of the prime minister
saying that he wasn't at events that he
quite clearly was at because other
photographs have been take being given
to sue
gray well we've had um weeks and weeks
of questions
about these events you've had
you've had lots of you've had lots of my
colleagues on your show
asking questions about these events and
they're a very serious
issues happening across the world i mean
this
threat that russia is making to ukraine
uh could have severe consequences not
just for europe but for global security
which is why
we are doing so much to
stop uh to
to get russia to desist maybe we need um
a third female prime minister to
navigate us through that
i've got absolute confidence in our
prime minister he's doing a great job
including on russia ukraine where the uk
is leading the effort to support
defensive weapons into ukraine to lead
the international sanctions effort he's
doing a lot of work to persuade our
allies to do more particularly to reduce
european dependence on russian gas we
are out of time i would love to talk to
you for longer hopefully you will be
able to come back soon thank you always
a pleasure to have you great to see you
thank you very much indeed thank you
quick look at how the papers are looking
at events this morning the telegraph
says that boris johnson is under
pressure to release the full version of
sugray's report into parties at downing
street during lockdown
the metro declares you've had your
parties now here is the bill
upon of course on what we call the
police service in this country uh the
met saying that they will investigate
numbers up pm that's the front page of
the mirror as they say sue gray has
obtained pictures of boris johnson with
wine bottles at the alleged number 10
parties
the star is also reporting on those
photographs their headline is simple
blanca
and in the express they say that the
public now wants a line drawn under
these allegations as boris johnson
apparently welcomed the police probe
from scotland yard
ambrose johnson will come under more
scrutiny in the house of commons this
afternoon there'll be full and live
coverage of prime minister's questions
here on sky news at midday
still to come this morning though
as the government awaits sugray's much
anticipated report into ministerial
misconduct during lockdown we'll hear
from the shadow education secretary
bridget phillipson
we'll get into the legalities of sue
gray's report and the met police's
investigation into events at downing
street with the legal commentator joshua
rosenberg
as world leaders struggle to find a
diplomatic solution to the ukraine
crisis speaking to the former uk
ambassador to russia sir roderick line
to see how likely he thinks it will be
meantime president biden has suggested
the united states could target russian
president vladimir putin with personal
sanctions if he orders an invasion
something we just asked the foreign
secretary about she says she would not
rule that out will we clearer in the
next few days our international affairs
editor dominic waghorn is in the
ukrainian capital of kiev and sent us
this report
[Music]
hundreds of millions of dollars worth of
american munitions and equipment
airlifted to ukraine
back home eight and a half thousand
troops on standby to be sent to the
region
and america's president warning russia's
leader he will be held responsible for
any attack on ukraine i made it clear to
uh early on to
president putin that if he were to move
into
ukraine that there'd be severe
consequences including
significant economic sanctions as well
as
i'd feel obliged to beef up our presence
nato's presence in
on the eastern front
not since the cold war has been such
urgent diplomatic activity amongst
western allies in support of ukraine and
trying despite their divisions to hold
the line with russia
we are completely united and coordinated
in the face of that situation
as european member states as allied
countries
within the north atlantic treaty
organisation
russia continues to put on a show these
are ballistic missiles being put through
their paces near the border with europe
scheduled exercises but stoking tensions
[Applause]
while allies continue sending security
assistance to ukraine and the region the
message to ukrainians today has been
don't panic the government telling them
the situation is under control an
invasion is not imminent
while everyone tries to second guess
moscow's next move
but vladimir putin's intentions are
still a mystery is he waiting for
weather cold enough to favor a ground
invasion or is he still hoping diplomacy
will deliver concessions
tensions are being felt from the black
sea to the baltic where denmark is
strengthening nato's forces after 20
russian vessels put out to sea
for now russia's military continues
limbering up in the snow performing for
the cameras while the west does what it
can to deter it from being used in anger
dominic waghorn sky news kiev
should he be personally sanctioned that
is a question for joe biden he said yes
as far as president putin is concerned
just putting that to the foreign
secretary as well as trusts here in the
studio within the last few moments she
says
she's not ruling it out and we'll hear
more within the next few days continuing
coverage of what's happening in ukraine
here on the programme meantime back at
home more than one in 20 children were
off school last thursday as the impact
of the pandemic amongst the youngest at
least shows no sign of abating
94 300 new cases of coronavirus
confirmed in the uk in the last 24 hours
and another 439 deaths that takes the
number of deaths within 28 days of a
positive test for covert 19 to 154
356.
meanwhile scientists from imperial
college london have uh released more
details of studies into the prevalence
of the virus looks a little bit uh like
this in the form of melano who's
standing by at the department of health
for us hi melania what is it saying
hi kay well the study found that there
are unprecedented levels of covet in the
community and that at this time omicron
has pretty much replaced delta as the
dominant variant and found that between
the 5th and the 20th of january 1 in 23
people in england had covered and that
is the highest level since the study
began in may of 2020 and this study is
considered to be one of the most
reliable snapshot of the status of the
virus in the community because it tests
people up and down the country whether
they're symptomatic or not interestingly
it is primary age school children who
have the most virus more than seven
percent of them have had courage during
that time period but among the adult
population their aids are actually
falling and perhaps not surprising their
school children have been affected
because they've just come back to school
they're mixing a lot more than they
would have during the christmas break
now what the scientists say is good is
it seems that the raids have peaked
around the 5th of january and then
started falling down stabilizing at the
middle of the month what's not so great
is that they stabilize at a fairly high
level and uh health secretary sergey
javid reacting to this study said that
while the data in many ways is
encouraging it does show that you still
need to take precautions and he took
this as an opportunity to encourage
everyone who's not yet had their booster
to book one
okay thank you thanks a lot
uh now music's very own rocket man has
had to take a break from orbit after
testing positive
for covid19
[Music]
yep quite a bit of time on his hands at
the moment uh the music legend elton
john had to postpone some dates of his
us tour after contracting the virus he
is uh fully vaccinated he says his
symptoms are mild and has already
reshared you all the dates he's had to
cancel um what an absolute fantastic
voice that man has uh let's take a stay
in the us actually the coast guard
continuing to search for 39 people
after a boat capsized off the coast of
florida the vessel capsized around 45
miles east of fort pierce inlet which is
found on the coast of florida's infamous
panhandle
guards found one lone survivor clinging
to the boat my goodness he said they hit
bad weather after setting out from the
bahamas and that no one was wearing a
life vest it's believed the vessel was
being used
for people smuggling
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you now
and a woman who was stabbed to death
before her suspected killer was killed
by a car in west london has been named
by the police
she was 43 year old yasmin caffee she
was pronounced dead in chippenham road
in maida vale after suffering several
stab wounds to the neck the man who died
after being hit by a vehicle has been
named as 41 41-year-old leon mccasker
hundreds of children remained trapped
inside a prison in syria after it was
seized by members of islamic state
nearly a week ago
u.s backed kurdish forces have attempted
to retake the jail which is located in
the city of hasakah
the game of thrones actor peter dinklage
has criticized disney's remake of snow
white and the seven dwarves describing
it as backward
dinklage whose stars in a new film
serano has accused the studio of double
standards supporting racial diversity
while conveying other damaging
stereotypes
quick look at the weather for you
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
rain will move into the north on
strengthening winds today but much of
the south looks dry there'll be a
largely dry start to the day with
extensive cloud meaning most places will
be frost free
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
one of the pictures that we loved uh
this morning paris fashion week here we
go it's known for its weird and
wonderful creations uh but take a look
at this for something a little bit
different
but that's what you call a clothes horse
charlotte casigari the granddaughter of
princess grace kelly of monaco appeared
on the runway on an actual horse racing
an actual horse a horse named cusco
seemed to have enjoyed it its first uh
runway or catwalk experience trotting
around the elaborate set design before
it broke out as you saw into a canter
there most impressive
as world leaders struggle to find a
diplomatic solution to the ukraine
crisis speaking to the former uk
ambassador to russia sir rodrik line to
see how likely he thinks it will become
hello again everybody our top story is
for you this morning the prime minister
now waits to discover his fate as the
official report into whether lockdown
rules were broken
could be published as early as today
prime minister's questions midday today
more talks
are due to take place in paris today
over the ukraine crisis president biden
has threatened to impose personal
sanctions on vladimir putin if russia
invades we're hearing from our own
foreign secretary that potentially
britain could do the same
a new study from imperial college london
has found a sharp decrease in cases of
covin 19 however the dip has now
decreased has now increased after
children have returned to school
[Music]
pressure growing on the prime minister
today with a sue gray report into
alleged downing streets expected to land
in his inbox
imminently not there yet earlier i asked
the foreign secretary who has been
tipped as a front runner to succeed the
pm should he go whether she fully
supports mr johnson
the prime minister has appeared before
parliament
he has apologized uh for what has
happened he's admitted that mistakes
were made and i 100 support him
and want him to continue as prime
minister
tamara's standing by at downey street
for us this morning still not got the
report then tomorrow
morning k no officials in number 10
confirmed to me this morning that they
have not received the sue grey report
and they'll need a few hours to digest
it before the prime minister goes to
parliament to give that promised
statement and take questions so it could
happen later today but it may drift into
tomorrow i'll bring you more on those
timings and meanwhile the prime
minister's opponents are organizing the
prime minister's supporters are
organizing to try and shore him up but
as westminster holds its breath for this
report members of the cabinet like liz
truss are waiting watching and waiting
to see what that report brings and which
way the wind is blowing in terms of the
prime minister's fate yesterday the
police announced they were investigating
that's not a place any prime minister
wants to be the question now is whether
what we learn in this report leads to
tory mp's acting even before that
investigation comes back okay tomorrow i
just want to share with our viewers this
morning good morning wherever you're
watching us around the world the senior
police officer leading the investigation
into parties at downing street who is
she
the deputy assistant commissioner jane
connors she leads the met police's
enforcement for covert 19 last year she
was forced to defend the services
handling of the sarah everard vigil on
clapham common after clashes between
police mourners
so that's her that's the lady who will
be looking into it also ask the foreign
secretary if she went to any parties um
during lockdown
this is what she said
did you go to any parties that's not
speculation i didn't any
no were you ever invited
no
are you hesitated
oh no i wasn't
okay definitely no parties then tomorrow
for the foreign secretary we do know
that uh
rishi sunak uh certainly was in the
cabinet room when cake was being given
to the prime minister
well she said it was a no to being
invited or going to any we know rishi
sunak turned up to a covid meeting at
the end of the prime minister's birthday
perhaps caught a bit of the the cake and
singing i haven't had that aspect of it
confirmed what we know okay is that sue
gray's report is going to paint a
picture of going on goings on in downing
street that will outrage many people who
were locked in their homes and following
the rules exactly who it touches who saw
what who was there who organized it is
what we're waiting to find out
okay tomorrow thank you tomorrow's take
at nine o'clock um number ten we are
hearing like the rest of us still
waiting for the sioux gray report could
happen as early as today
probably not tomorrow it's a holocaust
day tomorrow so
unlikely that it will be tomorrow that
takes us into
friday lots of mps away and their
constituencies for the weekend does that
take us into next week or could it be
this morning dunno if you're watching
prime minister let us know if you're
watching this grey let us know other
news world leaders are continuing to try
to find a diplomatic solution to the
ukraine crisis with talks being held in
paris today
boris johnson has committed british
troops to eastern europe if russia
invades ukraine while the u.s is
exploring sanctions on vladimir putin
himself with us now is the uh former uk
ambassador to russia sir rodrigue thank
you so much for taking the time to join
us this morning i was putting to the
foreign secretary a little bit earlier
on whether or not
the uk would fall behind the united
states and um
put personal sanctions against president
putin do you think that would make any
difference well i think the first thing
is it was quite clear that president
biden was talking off the cuff
and vladimir putin i don't suppose has
any plans to take his grandchildren to
disneyland or the tower of london in the
near future
i don't think personal sanctions on
putin would constitute any kind of a
deterrent they'd probably boost his
popularity in russia
um and i rather doubt if countries like
france or germany would follow this so i
wouldn't uh i wouldn't take that too
seriously it's not a big deterrent
okay so what would be
um
certainly the sort of fairly major
sanctions that the west is preparing
also the fact that
uh the more that russians push forward
militarily the more that nato is going
to have to reinforce as britain has made
clear and other nato countries to make
clear the countries on the
uh the borders of ukraine and belarus
frontline states like poland and so on
that's absolutely the reverse of what
russia actually claims to want
um we're not at that point yet uh we're
in a stage of a lot of saber rattling
the russians using the threat of an
invasion to try to force concessions out
of the western concessions out of
ukraine but uh we're still at the stage
of talking as you mentioned in your
report there's going to be a meeting in
paris today that's not at a very senior
level it's a continuation of the
normandy process which has been going on
for eight years and has failed to find a
settlement to the
border question in ukraine much more
seriously later this week the americans
have promised to give the russians a
written response to the russian demands
that may or may not lead to serious
negotiations we have to wait and see
um as an ambassador to russia previously
which do you think they take more
seriously is it economic sanctions that
can be crippling but in both directions
thinking particularly about a gas line
that we
are rather attached to
or is it the threat of military
sanctions military activity
i think they need to take both seriously
but neither is going to [ __ ] russia
uh gas is a two-aged weapon i mean we in
britain don't of course buy russian gas
but we would suffer a spike in energy
prices which are already very very high
uh but the russians need to sell gas
it's their biggest single export
commodity and they can cut it off for a
short time but it starts to hurt them
fairly soon so you know there is a lot
of downside for russia i think the big
calculation that mr putin has to make as
he looks at his different options he's
keeping his options very open
are the costs of different forms of
action against ukraine the long-term
costs to russia and there are no good
military options for russia there are
options that might give them control of
ukraine but would give them an
absolutely huge headache for years and
years to come
on top of sanctions on top of a wider
chasm with the west and on top of
becoming more dependent on china since
2014 russia has been very isolated in
the world very dependent on china but
the russians privately they never say
this in public see china as a long-term
strategic threat to russia so that's a
very uncomfortable position for them and
i think putin has got himself into a
hole and i think there's a danger for
him that he doesn't go down the path of
negotiation which at the moment doesn't
look very likely that he's going to dig
russia deeper into a hole
final thought before i let you go mr
ambassador so you feel that he's doing
this to try to remain relevant
no i think he's doing this because the
number one strategic priority of russian
foreign policy
uh for years and years has been to try
to gain control of ukraine that's not
necessarily to occupy ukraine but it's
to have a veto over ukraine it is to
keep the west out of ukraine it is to
establish a sphere of influence in the
territories that used to be in the
soviet union which is dominated by
russia and where they can effectively
repel
too much of a drift towards the west
he's failed for eight years to achieve
that objective he's now decided at a
time when the west looks quite weak and
divided to try to bring it to a head and
to see if threats and coercion can get
him over the line uh but it's been a
tale of failure for putin up to now
okay um mr former mr ambassador thank
you so much for joining us with your
expertise from southwest london this
morning slightly warmer than i'm sure
they are in russia today thank you
thank you
got a special report for you from
ukraine now with our chief correspondent
uh stuart ramsey who spent the day at a
top secret ukrainian base where intense
training is underway in preparation
for potential russian invasion
it's not a secret what weapons systems
and equipment the ukrainian military has
where they keep it though most certainly
is this camp is top secret hidden in
woods in the dinettes region of eastern
ukraine
sky news is the first media organization
to ever film here
if there is going to be a resistance to
an invading russian force
it'll come from here
this is the country's main tank
battalion in the south east as the
tension continues to grow over a
potential invasion the tank crews are
undergoing intense training
they're working on evasion tactics
knowing that they'll be outgunned by the
russian forces more sophisticated
equipment and more importantly its sheer
numbers
the military's top brass are coming to
inspect this base
the tanks are usually concealed in
positions in miles of snowy forest
with a gas turbine engine they sound
more like a jet fighter than the old
diesel-powered tank
these t-80b 1v vehicles are upgraded
versions of older designs
they're widely regarded as better than
the tanks used by the russians
the ukraine military has been taking
delivery of as many as they can get
since the separatist uprising in donbass
and the russian annexation of crimea
an investment that now appears wise
these are the most sophisticated
attacks available to the ukrainian
military it's why they keep them hidden
it's going to be vitally important
that they're operational and are kept
safe
in case the russians invade it's the
best protection they've got
the tanks carve up the earth as they
maneuver
bear in mind it's pretty much frozen
both armies could quite easily find
themselves bogged down
it's not lost on any of these tank crews
how intense things could get
everyone's talking about a potential
russian invasion
are you preparing for this i mean has
life changed at all or does everything
just carry on as normal
a
[Music]
experts do not believe that if an
invasion takes place there will be
actual world war ii style tank battles
on open planes
tactics and missile systems are
different now
but in the current uncertainty of what
may happen
absolutely nothing can be ruled out
stuart ramsey sky news eastern ukraine
those freezing temperatures are exactly
what they want in beijing at the moment
winter olympics just over a week away
the opening ceremony the use of
artificial snow is posing tough
environmental questions for officials
the games will be first to rely on
almost 100 of artificial snow using more
than 222 million liters of water tom
standing by in beijing for us why do
they have to create their own snow tom
and how bad they sometimes have to add
chemicals today as well
yeah this is all man-made snow one of
the issues with holding the winter
olympics in beijing forget the
diplomatic boycotts forget the air
quality uh index is the fact it doesn't
snow in beijing it's incredibly dry
place it is a cold place but it is very
very dry so they're going to have to
create all this snow using a tremendous
amount of water that's around 74
olympic sized swimming pools of water to
make this snow so that is raising
questions about how green these games
are going to be despite the fact that
beijing says they will be
entirely green energy powered this water
is an issue especially because beijing
doesn't have that much water it's very
difficult to supply this city with water
so questions being asked and also
mentioned in this report by luffy
university is it's not just bad for the
environment it's bad for athletes when
you use artificial snow instead of
natural snow it's a lot icier so that
leads to snow being packed down it's
gritty and there's a greater potential
for athletes to fall and injure
themselves so they'll be on alert about
that this isn't necessarily just about
beijing this is a warning specifically
about beijing because the games are
going to start here but this report says
this is going to be an issue going into
the future other winter resorts are
making their own snow this is only going
to get worse they want people to focus
more on climate when it comes to
awarding games to cities for any sort of
sporting event okay thanks tom thanks a
lot
now unless you are good at guessing it's
not much use being a detective those are
famous words of which super may i miss
you
that i give to
i you the way he says it uh do you know
what nationality is
known for his yes you do where we get
the director saying no she doesn't know
she does it's one of those name three
famous belgians that's one of them known
for his standout performances as the
moustache twirling investigator in
agatha christie's poirot the actor sir
david susheer has received a knighthood
at windsor castle 75 year old said it
was his proudest moment to be honored
for services to drama
can you name two other famous belgians
i'll leave that one with you
uh muscles from brussels being one of
them leaving you just one let's get more
on the downing street parties now and
the legalities around the sugrey report
and the met police's own investigation
into events in number 10. joining us now
to explain the implications our legal
eagle joshua rosenberg hey joshua thanks
for joining us um this morning goodness
me what a mess this is
what happens next as far as the police
investigation is concerned what are they
looking at
they will be investigating some of the
findings of sue gray's report we of
course haven't seen that it's not clear
whether we're going to see that today
but to during her investigation sue gray
kept in touch with the metropolitan
police and yesterday the commissioner
made it clear that some offenses were
sufficiently serious for the met to
investigate other offences alleged were
less serious and wouldn't be
investigated so we can expect the police
to spend some time interviewing
witnesses perhaps interviewing suspects
and reaching conclusions on whether they
think criminal offences have been
committed and joshua if the prime
minister is interviewed under caution he
would be the first prime minister ever
for that to happen too tony blair said
if you do that i'm going to resign
if if he is interviewed a question under
caution what does that what does that
actually mean do they read him he's
right so how does that proceed
yes they read him his rights and they
say you don't have to say anything but
if you do it may be used in evidence
against you and the point about that is
that if he were to be interviewed under
caution he would clearly be a suspect
boris johnson would be in those
circumstances somebody suspected of
committing a criminal offence now you
may say
not a terribly serious criminal offence
but a criminal offence nevertheless and
tony blair as you say
his officials told the police who were
investigating
honors breaches when he was prime
minister that if he was interviewed
under caution he would have to resign
because of the implication that the
prime minister had committed a crime
misconduct in public office apparently
is also something that could be
investigated
this is a common law offense meaning it
was laid down by the judges meaning it
was it is terribly vague and unclear and
it also means that there is no maximum
penalty life imprisonment in fact is is
the maximum penalty in theory um now
this is quite different from breaches of
the coronavirus regulations where the
normal thing would be a fixed penalty
perhaps 100 pounds unless it was
challenged in the courts
whether this amounts to misconduct in a
public office is is quite a difficult
question of law it's one on which i
think the police would need to take
careful advice from the crown
prosecution service maybe from
independent lawyers that would make
things much more complicated than a
fairly straightforward question of
whether the lockdown regulations were
breached
and and yesterday when this story first
dropped i said get that joshua rosenberg
on the telly because i didn't understand
my essential offer journalist is not
good enough to know whether the report
could be published by sue gray while the
police are investigating that's a very
interesting question kay and you're
absolutely right the principle behind
essential law for journalists is that
you don't prejudice a forthcoming trial
if people are under investigation by the
police for criminal offences we don't
discuss uh what happened on the media
because it might prejudice the jury
however in this particular case there's
very little prospect of a jury trial
this would be dealt with in a
magistrate's court possibly by a
district judge sitting alone
and so it seems to me that there's very
little prospect now yesterday downing
street was suggesting that sue gray's
report would be edited to remove
references to cases that might come
before the court
that was something that raised a lot of
concern and metropolitan police say as
far as we're concerned we're perfectly
happy for it to be published i think
that's the right approach i can't see
any prospect of prejudicing a trial and
if there was a prospect it's much more
important the political debate should be
properly informed in my view i'm writing
all that down in my shorthand so that i
can put that to the minister tomorrow um
are we in a position where every single
person that went to those parties
alleged parties let's see what sue gray
says just put that rider in there could
be issued with a fixed penalty notice
and if that's the case does that mean
they have a criminal record
in theory i suppose anybody who
deliberately went to a party and
assuming that it was a breach of the
lockdown regulations which seems pretty
clear
although it's quite complicated yes in
theory they they could be
but
in reality uh
the metropolitan police commissioner
dame crested made it very clear
yesterday that she would be looking at
the more serious cases i think a fixed
penalty notice uh isn't quite on the
same level as a criminal offense
but it is obviously an admission of
criminal wrongdoing
and it's not the sort of thing that you
would like to have
i think you could compare it to a
speeding penalty uh which is a serious
matter
but perhaps not something that bars you
from high office if you're a judge you
can possibly
still carry on if you admit to certain
parking offenses and other offences so
it is a serious matter but it's not
quite as serious as a conviction in the
criminal courts joshua out of time i
need a one-word answer could the person
who organized any of these parties find
themselves with a ten thousand pound
fine for organizing a party yes or no
it is possible you can't rule it out
good to talk to you as always thank you
joshua thanks for the explanation
he's so clever isn't he so clever have a
quick look at this lady she's not quite
as well known as sue gray but she's
getting there she is lulu little
saying absolutely
nothing
about
that cake
in the cabinet room
[Music]